dans la carrière de prenois pelleteuse
et chargeurs sont de retour sur le
chantier depuis mi avril
désormais cette entreprise de travaux
publics tentent de se relancer mais le
volume d'activité depuis le début de
l'année s'est réduit de moitié par
rapport à 2019
conséquence le patron a dû se séparer de
ses intérimaires les intérimaires
l'entreprise pennequin en général c'est
5 % de notre effectif nous avons 80
salariés
ça fait cas de personnes aujourd'hui
nous sommes à 0 personnes en intérim du
fait d'avoir été arrêté nous avons pas
repris l'activité normale encore à ce
jour
les appels d'offres sont peu nombreux
donc nous n'avons pas repris
d'intérimaires l'intérim
le secteur s'est effondré pendant la
crise sanitaire en bourgogne franche
comté
l'activité a plongé jusqu'à -50 9% en
avril de mars à mai 23 1750 postes ont
été supprimés dans cette agence
d'intérim
oui ces deux nouveaux rachats de ses
partenaires on a assisté à l'hécatombe
l'activité a baissé de 40 % en avril les
secteurs les plus impactés commencé en
scène les premiers commerces
restauration qui aujourd'hui ont fermé
les btp qui n'ont pas pu ouvrir leurs
chantiers comme à l'habitude depuis la
crise de 2008 on n'avait jamais connu ça
la crise sanitaire
une épreuve supplémentaire pour les
étudiants à la recherche d'emplois
saisonniers pendant le confinement anaïs
la rue aps a envoyé une trentaine de
candidatures sans succès pour l'instant
vous de la situation sanitaire c'est
difficile tout d'abord parce que ça a
retardé
de l'e recrutement etc mi avril
donc je suis à la boulangerie près de
chez moi et je leur ai demandé donc si
il recrutait pendant les grandes
vacances et elle m'a dit je cite on ne
sait pas revenu plus tard voilà donc j'y
suis retourné après confinement et
c'était exactement la même chose qu'on
sait pas ramener plus tard la crise n'a
pas impacté tous les secteurs aussi
violemment la grande distribution fait
figure d'exception dans ce supermarché
20 saisonniers l'an dernier ils seront
autant cet été